joseph m bessette is alice tui tui
professor of government and ethics at
claremont mckenna college
and senior research fellow at the
claremont graduate university
he received his bs and physics from
boston college and his ma
and phd in political science from the
university of chicago
dr bessette is the author or co-author
of numerous books
including the mild voice of reason
deliberative democracy
and american national government
american government
and politics deliberation democracy and
citizenship
and by man shall his blood be shed a
catholic defense of capital punishment
co-editor and contributor to the
presidency in the constitutional order
the constitutional presidency and the
imperial presidency and the constitution
and editor of toward a more perfect
union the writings of herbert j's story
please welcome joseph bessette
[Applause]
well thank you very much for that kind
introduction
um i'll talk a little bit about how
we're going to deal with the technical
glitches that have come up here uh last
few minutes
but first let me just say it's a great
pleasure for me to be here this is my
first visit to hillsdale
i have been a big fan of this
institution
and an avid reader of in primus or in
primus whichever it is you know what i'm
talking about
for three or more more than three
decades
i have seen good friends former
colleagues and students
find their way into your community and
make their own distinctive contribution
to the continuing
and growing excellence of this
outstanding institution
so i'm very honored to be asked to
contribute to this program on foreign
policy
now let me just say a word about the
technical complications so i had
i had built my talk around uh powerpoint
slides with quotations from founding
documents
i can see them right here and i guess
but you can't see them behind me maybe
before we're done you'll be able to see
them so
i'm going to make adjustments but you
will have to pay close attention
i'll have to read from these documents
that you otherwise would be able to see
so it presents
challenges for us and we'll of course do
the best we can
with those challenges i would i would be
reading from them anyway but i was
hoping obviously you'd be able to
see what i was reading um so anyway
we'll we'll do the best we can
and uh i'm hopeful this will be
successful um
so the topic is separation of powers and
foreign policy but that's much
too big a topic to try to cover in the
next 30 or 40 or
45 minutes actually i want to shut off
my phone
and also set it up for the time so i can
see how much
how the time is going by
i don't know if anyone else was going to
stop me if i went too long but
but anyway i'll i will try to
self-regulate but let me
let me shut this off
okay all right good um
so uh so i'm gonna concentrate focus
entirely on one aspect of separation
of of separation powers and foreign
policy which is the war power
so this is the aspect of foreign policy
that i know best
this is what i've been studying and
teaching especially the claremont
graduate university
over the past 30 years i do some of my
writing on
and in particular i want to focus on
this issue regarding the war powers
who gets to decide whether to send
american troops into combat
on the high seas or in or in the skies
above a foreign nation
who gets to decide that is this mainly a
matter
for congress to decide or for the
president
or for the two branches and a kind of
collaborative effort
or does this or does the answer to this
question simply vary case by case
and in particular what guidance does the
constitution give us
in trying to resolve who gets to decide
whether to go to war
overseas on the high seas or in a
foreign country
some many scholars
view the constitution as providing not
much formal guidance but merely
that it creates an invitation to
congress and the presidency to struggle
over foreign policy and over the war
powers and as i
as i think you'll see i don't agree with
that view
i think the congress provides the
constitution provides a lot more
guidance than
a lot of people a lot of scholars give
it
give it credit for so i want to lead you
through some
key materials brief excerpts from
six or seven or eight different founding
documents and then
see and then i won't have time in the
formal presentation to apply
what we learned from the founding
documents to contemporary issues
but i am prepared to talk about uh the
war powers act of 1973 which is not part
of my formal address prepared to talk
about
reagan versus obama's bombing of libya
and whether what we're going to learn in
the next half hour so is relevant to
trying to
determine whether they were
constitutional or not so have some
material prepared that might come up in
the
in the q a so the the documents
that we're going to cover are
the following obviously the most
authoritative is the constitution itself
we're going to look at key provisions in
the constitution we're going to look at
one
very brief debate on august 17th
at the constitutional convention of 1787
the only debate that occurred on war
powers that we have a record of
we're going to look at some very
interesting features of the south
carolina constitutions of 1776
in 1778 then in my original plan we're
going to talk about
a very different view of war powers in
the massachusetts constitution but i'm
going to skip that and maybe that'll
come up in the q a
and then a little bit from alexander
hamilton's federalist 70 that some of
you might be
familiar with about the need for a
unitary executive
and then the most famous war powers
debate of the founding era which is
you may not have heard of this uh and
they use latin pseudonyms but it's
pacificus versus helvidius 1793 i'll
explain it when we come to it
but pacificus is hamilton and helvidius
is madison
so there's a big debate in the written
newspapers of the time in pamphlets and
newspapers
although under under these pseudonyms
but it quickly became known who
was the author of each of these sets of
essays and then
the very first supreme court case to
take up the war powers was in 1800
and it's the name of the case was bass v
tingey
and there's a couple of paragraphs in
that case that'll be very helpful to us
i think they're very useful to us
in understanding the history and the
contemporary issues about
the application of the war power
so let's start with the constitution
so we'll start with the constitution on
congress and then the constitution on
the presidency that's the order in which
you know the branches occur in the
constitution article 1 is on congress
article 2 won the presidency
so you might be familiar with these
provisions
so one of them is especially important
but let me just
read the list of powers so there's 18
powers
in article 1 section 8 vested in the
constitution
invested in congress by the constitution
and some of them
have to do with international relations
and war matters so what are those
first to define and punish piracies and
felonies committed on the high seas
and offenses against the law of nations
and then the most important one for our
purpose is to declare war
congress has the power as you all know
i'm sure to declare war
also to grant letters of mark and
reprisal
and make rules concerning captures on
the land and water
i'll come back in a minute to this odd
phrase letters of marketing reprisal
third to raise and support armies but no
appropriation of money to that use shall
be for longer than two years
so congress typically has one year
budgets but it's prohibited from having
say a five-year budget
to the army because the
constitution authors didn't want the
executive branch to have that much
flexibility five years worth of funding
but typically congress provides one-year
funding every year they fund the
military
and i won't say a lot about this in the
talk but you know one way in which
congress
can combat a president who they think is
out of control in terms of war powers
is to deny the president funding and the
most
maybe the most famous example of this is
in june of 73 congress passed a law
that pro so this is at the end of the
vietnam war period there are no american
combat troops in vietnam but the
war is still going on the south
vietnamese against the viet cong and the
north vietnamese but the american troops
have all been withdrawn
congress passes a law saying after a
certain date in august
no more money can be spent by the
federal government for any military
operations in southeast asia
that meant when in early january of 1775
a large army from north vietnam flooded
into south vietnam
the u.s was the president then general
ford then richard nixon earlier was
prohibited from providing any military
assistance
so congress can very much affect the war
powers through
funding congress provides and maintains
a navy it makes rules and regulations
of of the land and naval forces uniform
code of military justice
something congress passes it provides
for calling forth the militia to execute
the laws of the union to suppress
insurrections
and to repel invasions so
congress writes the law that'll that
determines
how the president it doesn't cause it
doesn't itself
call the militia into service the
militia is what we call the national
guard so
there's a michigan national guard i live
in california there's a california
national guard
and they're under the control of their
governors unless they're nationalized
unless they're called into national
service which they sometimes are
and for one of three reasons they can be
called international service to execute
the laws to suppress and suppress
to suppress insurrections or to repel
invasions
now i'm not going to talk about the use
of the war power domestically
one of my favorite topics i speak about
it a lot i teach about it a lot
is lincoln's use of the war power during
the civil war
but lincoln didn't think it was the
confederacy was another country
obviously uh it was all one country so
that's purely domestic use
and that's not on my on on on the on the
on my agenda for tonight's
conversation i'm just going to be
talking about the exercise of war power
vis-a-vis other countries or other
international organizations like
terrorist organizations
so those are the oh so those are the the
powers of congress but what the heck is
a letter of mark and reprisal
i don't know if anybody here has ever
heard the phrase we don't use them
anymore
letters of mark and reprisal so what
they were
were letters that the sovereign would
issue to a private citizen
typically someone who had a ship with
guns
sometimes called privateers a private
person with a ship with
guns a little private military force
which
if that private person with the ship
with guns were to go out into the ocean
and
capture the goods off another ship you
would call that person a pirate
and they would be subject to being uh
captured and summarily executed
but if they have one of these letters
the letter is a letter from the
sovereign that authorizes that private
person
with the ship with the guns to act on
behalf of the sovereign
like act as if he's part of the military
of the sovereign
and therefore if he's captured on the
high seas doing something authorized by
this letter
then he could be captured but he would
not be treated as a pirate he'd be
treated as a
prisoner of war and that the end of the
war would normally be repatriated
so but notice it's congress that can
issue these letters
not the president now now we don't
actually issue such letters anymore
because countries have their own navies
but there was a time when sovereigns
would issue such letters
to private individuals to act on their
behalf militarily
and that authority interestingly in the
constitution is given to the congress
not the president now let's talk about
the
uh the president's authorities um
so the obviously the one that is maybe
most
at issue or the one you most think about
is the president is the
commander-in-chief
right of the army and navy of the united
states and of the militia if the militia
is called into national service
he's always the commander-in-chief of
the army and navy and now we have of
course
air force and then the marines are
technically part of
as you might know part of the navy he's
always in command the commander-in-chief
of the army and navy but he's only in
the commander-in-chief of the state
militia when they're nationalized when
they're called into national service
so that's the one we always think of but
there are three other provisions
of article two that are very relevant to
this constitutional issue of war powers
the first one is the begin so is
is the beginning words of article two so
on my slide
everything on my slide for those who
might be viewing it elsewhere these are
all direct quotes from article two
and article two begins the executive
power shall be vested in a president of
the united states of america
now as we'll see in a few minutes
hamilton thought that that clause itself
gave over to the president
essentially all of the foreign policy
and war power
unless the constitution made some
exceptions
we'll see that argument in a few minutes
there's also
the well-known clause that the president
shall take care that the laws be
faithfully executed
now normally we think of that as
applying domestically but it can also
apply outside the united states
there are international treaties that
the u.s has
by the terms of the constitution itself
treaties are
part of the supreme law of the land so
the president presumably has some
authority to carry out treaties
and maybe those treaties carrying out
those treaties would have military
implications
there's also international law
and under international law american
citizens on the high seas or in some
other country
should be treated in a certain way by
other countries and if they're
mistreated
maybe the president under this clause
can come to their aid in some way
and then finally there's the oath of
office uh and you you probably all know
it you've all heard it you've probably
all watched a presidential
uh uh inauguration where the
where the president publicly gives takes
the oath of office
the end of it is that he solely promises
a swear to the best of his ability the
end of it is to preserve protect
and defend the constitution of the
united states
you've all heard the phrase now
interestingly
and this is maybe not as well known
every other person who works for the
federal government
and every every officer of a state or
local government must also take an
oath but under the constitution
all it says is they must take an oath to
support the constitution
now congress actually writes out the
words of the oath for everybody else
and so if you take it i've taken it four
or five times in my life i took it first
as as a summer employee of the post
office department delivering mail in
brockton massachusetts for two summers
when i was the age of the
students in the room here i had to take
this more elaborate oath that many of
you have heard
defend the country against all
aggressors foreign and domestic
i won't read it but the and and then i
worked in two different public positions
in cook county illinois and then in the
federal government i had to take the
oath again
but the constitution only requires that
the oath say you must support
the constitution unless you're the
president
then it says you must promise to
preserve protect and defend the
constitution
so the presidential oath is much more
emphatic
right to preserve protect and defend
seems like a much greater responsibility
than simply the obligation to support
the constitution
so maybe that can be the ground of war
powers as well
and i'm not going to talk about lincoln
except to mention that lincoln is the
first president
to use the oath of office as a grounding
for exercising
extraordinary war powers but that was
domestically during the civil war
so
so this is what those provisions that i
just went over
uh that's all that the earl the first
generation of american leaders that's
all they had
in terms of how the constitution divided
up the war power
that you may or may not know this but
the delegates of the constitutional
convention
so the convention met from late may to
september 17th
just last week we had constitution day
right that's september 17th
uh hillsdale had a program in i guess in
northern virginia that actually got
actually got national news uh uh as a
result of people who spoke on that
program
that was in celebration of constitution
day so the the convention met
with 55 men 42 were there at one time or
another 42 were present on the last day
september 17th and 39 of those 42 signed
the document
but they were sworn to secrecy they met
behind closed doors in a hot humid
philadelphia summer all the doors and
windows were closed
they were sworn to secrecy and for the
most part there were no leaks
of any real consequence it was a
different time
55 men could work on something for three
and a half months
and nobody leaked it what was going on
it was really
quite striking you wondered today if
that would be that would be possible
of course if we had a new constitutional
convention it would almost surely be
done in public because that was just the
norm today would be not to give
some number of men and women today the
opportunity to write a new constitution
and to do it secretly
so norms do change in addition there was
no
formal record of the resolutions and
votes at the constitutional convention
which is called the journal there was a
secretary who kept
a formal record of every resolution and
every vote the voting was done by states
every state got one vote no matter how
big in population or in territory
the journal wasn't published until 1818
a couple of decades later but
the record of the debates the best
record of the debates a few delegates
took
limited debates for a few days or a week
or so but james madison as you may know
who sometimes called the father of the
constitution which i think is an
accurate
term although he's not really the father
of the presidency
that's sort of another story but he was
the
appropriately termed later the father of
the constitution
james madison a delegate from virginia
36 years old
decided he would take a written record
of all the debates for as long as the
convention went uh met
and he got a good seat in front looking
forward out of the others you could hear
everybody and according to him he didn't
miss more than a few minutes for the
whole three and a half months
and and he recorded something from every
speaker
now it was still notes it wasn't a
transcript he wasn't
doing shorthand and uh
but it's notes over the course of three
and a half months
and when you publish james madison's
notes you get about a thousand pages of
printed material
these excerpts so
after 18 so those
madison's notes were published after his
death he died in 1836
and his notes were published in 1840 so
this is half a century
after the event occurred we finally the
nation finally had a record
of what was said and argued during those
three and a half months
so the first generation of americans who
were governed by the institutions
created in 1787
they had the actual words of the
document which i just showed you were
described to you i read to you
but they had no information about the
debates that produced those words
we now know and have known since 1840
that war powers were debated at the
convention for only one
part of one day this hugely
controversial and
important subject that has filled
hundreds of volumes by academics
and others was actually debated at the
constitutional convention for only one
part
of one day and the day was august 17th
which is one month before they finished
they finished on september 17th
so um i got the slide up and i'm going
to have to
just read to you from some of the slide
but
let me give you the background so the
convention
started meeting in late may and uh they
look at some
broad different plans the virginia plan
the new jersey plan
there's some great controversies they
they pass a lot of resolutions
and at the end of july they say okay we
have to stop as a group now of the group
of 55
and we've got to set up a committee and
it was a small committee of five
to take everything that's been done as
well as some other plans that people
have proposed so a man named charles
pinckney
had proposed a plan although it was not
debated in those earlier
first two months of the convention so
they gave
everything they had passed and pinkney's
plan some other stuff to this
to this committee and the committee
produced over a 10-day period so the
convention went on recess the full group
and the committee over 10-day period
produced
the dr what they call the draft
constitution
and they brought it to this main printer
named dunlap in
philadelphia who had printed the
declaration of independence and the
articles confederation
and they had him secretly produce 55
copies
no more which they then passed out at
the convention
and from the early august until
september 17th
they work through that draft
constitution
then at the very end they take
everything they've done and they create
another committee called the committee
of style which took everything they had
done
and put the final polish and form on the
constitution
right that was right like the week
before they finished up
so so what this slide is showing and
i'll read you part of it is
they're working through the draft
constitution which begins with
congress's structure and then congress's
powers
then it goes to the president's
structure and the president's powers
then it goes to the court
structure in the court's powers they're
working through line by line on august
17th
they and there's a long list of specific
powers that the draft constitution
proposes vesting in congress we call it
the enumerated powers right the
enumerated powers of congress
and one of them is the power quote to
make war
all right that's all it says the power
to make war
there's a debate then that occurs if you
if you just
read this at a normal pace it takes
under three minutes
i did it a couple times just to check
under three minutes
if you look at how much of the page it
filled up in madison's four or five
pages
for what was almost always a five to six
hour session
maybe it was 30 minutes and we're just
getting madison's
three-minute version right of a
30-minute debate right obviously
he's not taking shorthand he's not
trying to do a transcript right
try and do good clear accurate notes so
i want to read you so it's it's it's
short it's either a half an hour short
or it's even
you know three to five or ten minutes
short debate
uh but it's not a two hour debate that
we know right from just looking at the
structure of madison's uh product so
here's so pinckney is he's from south
carolina i'm not going to give you the
background of all the delegates where's
some time for that
but he says the first thing on so this
comes up and he gets up he gets
recognized by
washington who's the presiding officer
they stand up and then they get
recognized
and he says he's opposed to vesting this
power in the legislature
its proceedings were too slow it would
meet but once a year
the house of representatives would be
too numerous for such deliberations
the original house was 65 but they knew
it would quickly grow
into the hundreds as it did the original
senate was of course 26 13
states although when it first met had 22
because two states had not
yet ratified north carolina and rhode
island
the senate would be the best depository
being more acquainted with foreign
affairs and more capable of proper
resolutions
so pinkney would vest it in the senate
alone
and i'm skipping a little bit butler
then says
the objections against the legislature
lie in great degree against the senate
the reasons why it would be bad for the
house to have this power also would
apply for
for the smaller senate he butler
was for vesting the power in the
president who will have all the
requisite qualities and will not make
war but when the nation will support it
all right let's just give it to the
president the power to make war
uh the british king had the power to
make war
so this wouldn't be the first executive
chief executive that had the power
madison and albridge gary by the way
gary's name is known to all of us
in a as the beginning of a longer
political term
only he only the term softens the g
jerry
jerry mandering you've heard of
gerrymandering well that's from albert
garry his he pronounced it gary he
became the governor of massachusetts he
drew legislative maps
in weird forms that somebody thought
looked like a salamander in order to
benefit his political party
and it came into american political laws
gerrymandering
anyway madison and gary moved to insert
declare
striking out make war leaving to the
executive the power to repel sudden
attacks
now this is interesting so so they're
saying
make war should be shrunken at least a
little bit
to declare war and they'll win on this
by a seven to three vote their motion
will carry and we end up with the power
to declare war not the power to make war
so what's the justifications very brief
justification
this will leave to the executive the
power to repel sudden attacks
apparently they're concerned that if
congress has the power to make war
the president wouldn't be able on his
own under the constitution
to repel a sudden attack but sherman
madison always misspelled it shaman but
it's roger sherman of connecticut
rogers chairman of connecticut was
famous for having earlier in the
convention
made the strongest argument that the
president should be
entirely subordinate to the supreme will
of the society expressed in the
legislature
that he was alone his was a lonely voice
there were hardly anybody else there who
thought
that under this new constitution the
executive should be the mere
servant the mere servant chosen it will
by the legislature
kicked out of office it will by the
legislature so that's his that's an
interesting part of his background so he
says
he likes it the way it stands the
executive should be able to repel and
not
commence war make is better than declare
the latter narrowing the power too much
now what does this mean so he's
actually disagreeing with madison and
gary who think that in order to allow
the president to repel sudden attacks
you have to change make war to declare
war have to shrink it
gary says on the contrary he will he
basically says he will have anyway the
power to repel sudden attacks
even if congress has the power to make
war and what i'm worried about
gary is that you're shrinking it too
much
he doesn't say how much when you go from
from
make to declare you're leaving too much
in the hands of the president and then
gary speaking on his own referring back
to butler
says he never expected to hear in a
republic
a motion to empower the executive alone
to declare war
and then there's a few other brief
comments that we don't have to get into
just to save some time
and then there's a vote and and this
motion by
gary and madison wins seven to three and
that's where the power of congress to
declare war that's where it comes from
from that that vote and that's there's
no equivalent discussion of war powers
when they go through the presidency
the commander-in-chief and these other
provisions that we talked about this is
it
this three minute to 30 minute
conversation
so what are we to make of this brief
debate let me suggest
a couple of things well first we
shouldn't try to make too much of it
there's only seven who spoke
remember madison said anytime somebody
spoke he wrote it down
only seven who spoke they didn't speak
for very long we don't get very much
detail of just what this
dispute is all about so so we have to we
should be cautious about how much we can
extract from this little debate
uh i mean whole i i don't know if a
whole book but whole academic articles
are written about
these few words from this one famous
august 17th debate
uh you get together with a group of
constitutionalists and you say august
17th and everybody knows
what you're talking about so anyway i
would suggest there is
there are certain things we can conclude
relatively confidently first
there was little sentiment to allow the
president to simply be in charge of
decisions to go to war
it was a non-starter butler mentions it
no one comes to his support
there's no motion that gets seconded
there doesn't seem to be any sentiment
except for butler and maybe there's one
or two others who are silent
you might be silent because you realize
you have no chance of carrying the day
anyway there's little sentiment that
will just let the president like the
british king had this power can decide
whether to go to war
second point make war they did agree
by seven to three vote right that make
war was too broad a power to give to
congress
and that it should be constrained or
constricted or narrowed in some way
to declare war now what we don't know
and we'll talk
more about before we're done what we
don't know
is how much did they think it was
shrinking congress's power and expanding
the president's power
right because sherman thought it would
shrink congress's power too much
and expand the president's power too
much if you made that change but they
went ahead and made that change
but notice that in narrowing congress's
power more power went to the president
at least the power to repel sudden
attacks and
of feared maybe feared maybe even more
than that would reside with the
president so
if you think about it they haven't come
to the presidency yet
but they seem to they seem to be
thinking that
whatever we give to congress we're
taking away from the
presidency and if we cut down what we
give to congress we're leaving more with
the presidency
now if that's an accurate way to
understand this brief debate
then it in a very interesting way it
makes us think or perhaps conclude
that that they thought that the war
power by its nature
naturally belonged to the chief
executive
remember this is a this is a debate
about congress's power not a debate
directly right about a provision
under article 2 on the presidency
um so it's it's uh um it's it's useful
information it's a useful way of
thinking about this very brief debate
now interestingly though this was not
the first time that the leaders in the
new nation had written
a constitution between i'm going to
leave out the articles of confederation
which you've all heard about
because it did not create a separate
executive branch
so for this presentation tonight i'm not
even going to mention it how it dealt
with war
powers i'm actually working on a sort of
big book with a
former classmate and long time friend
and co-author named gary schmidt
who works at the american enterprise
institute who has spoken i don't know if
he's spoken this
kind of program you have but he's spoken
at clap at hillsdale
in the past uh he and i are working on a
big book this fall and we will have a
chapter on
not on war power only but on the powers
of presidency of the president congress
and we'll have a chapter on on the
articles and federation but i'm not
going to mention it here
but i do want to talk about the 11
states that wrote 12
constitutions between 1776 and 1784.
15 of the delegates at the
constitutional convention
had served on the bodies that wrote
those constitutions
and five or six of them were principally
involved
in the drafting of those state
constitutions so they so a lot of them
had prior experience
with with war powers issues but applied
at the state level
so every state but connecticut and rhode
island wrote a new constitution
and south carolina wrote twos that's how
you get 12.
connecticut and rhode island just kept
their old charter forms of government
because they had elected governors not
royal governors appointed by the king in
every other state there was a royal
governor appointed by the king
and in the first year or two of the
revolution those governors those world
governors fled
or they were deposed and so you had no
body to carry out the executive power
and so what they did at first was create
committees of safety
to carry out the executive power then
they wrote new constitutions and they
all created executive branches
to carry out the executive power so how
had these 11 states with their 12
constitutions manage the war power
in their constitutions one thing all the
states did was to make the governor the
commander-in-chief
every state made its governor the
commander-in-chief just as
today the governor of michigan is the
commander-in-chief of the militia
in michigan but notice that they did not
have to do this
uh they could have done they being the
those who wrote the state constitutions
they could have authorized the
legislators to choose a
commander-in-chief
who was answerable to them rather than
answerable to the governor
they could have done that just as the
continental congress in 1775
chose george washington to be the
commander-in-chief who was
answerable to it they could have done
that but they would but none of them did
that in every single state even though
most of the early states had powerful
legislatures and weak governors
not all of them but most of them even
those weak governors were made the
commander in chief of the armed forces
within their state now at the time of
the founding
the armed forces in the state
would would include the militia which is
all male citizens 16 to 45
i think able-bodied male citizens some
states allowed
free blacks to be in the militia and
some states limited it just to
just to whites in the militia
but states also had their own regular
forces and during the revolutionary war
some of those regular forces
came under the control of the
continental army but some did not
so there were these military forces in
the states during the revolutionary
period that the governors
every one of them was the
commander-in-chief of
now one constitution or one state with
two constitutions
let me call it up south carolina
did something that no other state did
and that the u.s constitution did not do
so this is what i'm going to read two
brief provisions
one from the 1776 constitution of north
carolina one from the 1780
1778 i should say my slide says 1787
which is wrong should be
the it was a typo it should be 1778.
so from 1776 the president and
commander-in-chief so
many of the states use that most use
this term governor
but some use the term president for the
for what we
call regularly the governor of the state
the president so the title of the
governor of
south carolina in 1776 was president and
commander-in-chief
shall have no power to make war or peace
or enter into any final treaty
without the consent of the general
assembly and legislative council
that was the upper chamber so and then
in 1778 they changed the name of the
president to governor
he's now he's governor
commander-in-chief he shall have no
power to commence war without prior
approval of the legislature
so to make war in the first one and then
to commence war
now interestingly no other state
put that kind of constraint on its
governor
and nor did the u.s constitution follow
that model
uh and maybe even more interestingly uh
you know this
this model was well known in fact i
mentioned the committee of detail it was
five members it was cheered by
john rutledge who was the most prominent
maybe citizen of south carolina at the
time
he had some prominent brothers as well
as edward rutledge and some others who
had high positions
but he had been governor for four years
in south carolina during the revolution
he wasn't governor in 1787 but he was
the chair of this committee
so he knew exactly so when they wrote up
the draft constitution
the committee that wrote the draft
constitution he knew exactly how the
constitution they were writing then in
philadelphia
could constrain presidential war making
but
far as we know he never proposed that
kind of constraint
and to the best of our knowledge no one
at the constitutional convention
proposed the south carolina type
language
for the u.s constitution i think that's
an important point
it's a point that was first made in the
scholarship on these topics by
a berkeley law professor named john
u-y-o-o
who's written extensively on on the
founding and on presidential power and
worked
in the in the second bush administration
uh some years ago and is now back back
at berkeley
he's the first one to really develop
this at this very important point that
that the delegates of the constitution
convention could have restrained the
president
in a more emphatic way in terms of going
to war if they had wanted to
because they knew the language to do it
and you were john rutledge they knew the
south carolina constitution
but they didn't go they didn't go that
way
uh now i'm not going to read this this
is
the massachusetts constitution which was
then really copied four years later by
new hampshire in its constitution gave a
vast amount of power to its
commander-in-chief and there's no
time to go through this but if any of
you are particularly interested
a distinctive feature of that
constitution which is where where i'm
from so i have i guess a little bit of
native pride
is that it's the oldest written
constitution still functioning
in the world today now it's not a
national constitution right it's a state
constitution but it's the oldest
written constitution still functioning
in the world today
and and if you look at the massachusetts
constitution today you can look it up
online
most states have thrown off their
original constitutions and written new
ones but i think
partly out of pride in massachusetts
they kept the original one they just
kept amending it
several hundred times so you can there's
a version online that has the original
with all the amendments and you know and
there's more amendments than there are
than there is original language but
anyway it's still this interesting point
so
to this point we've been talking about
powers
but we should say a word about structure
a word more about structure so
uh alexander hamilton so do i have
let me call up federalist 70. so some of
you the students here and others
may have come across this language but
freddler 70 is maybe the most important
federalist essay on the presidency
it's 67 through 77 around the presidency
and this may be the one that's the most
important
but what hamilton argues here
i'm going to summarize a bit he says
there are people who think
that you can't have a vigorous executive
and a republican government
together that a republican government
doesn't allow for a vigorous executive
and hamilton says we had better hope
those people are wrong
because we do because every every
government needs a vigorous executive
he says and he talks about he's the
phrase vigorous executive and about
energy in the executive and he says
energy in the executive is a leading
character in the definition of good
government
it is essential to the protection of the
community against foreign attacks
and then he goes on to give a longer
list of things in where to where it's
useful
administrating the laws preserving
domestic order
i'll skip that every man the least
conversant in roman history
knows how often that republic was
obliged to take refuge
in the absolute power of a single man
under the formidable title of
dictator uh the the roman experience was
well known
to the american the educated american
framers and the leaders
the romans rome was a republic from
roughly 500 bc to 100 bc
the roman republic had a very complex
governing set of governing institutions
different popular assemblies
different offices with different
responsibilities but it didn't
concentrate
power in any one person sufficiently
that if a real crisis arose domestic
like a civil war between the classes in
rome
or international of the city-states or
other foreign powers
they couldn't deal with the crisis with
their normal constitution so what they
did
and they did this for several hundred
years they would choose some
uh noble competent respected person and
make that person
dictator for up to six months
and they're really only two limits on
the power of that dictator
one was the limited time it had to stop
at six months could stop sooner
and the other was that the dictator
could not order the execution
of a roman citizen that had to be
approved by the popular assembly
so the the famous he's a semi-mythic
character but the most famous
dictator is someone named cincinnatus
after whom cincinnati is named and
the you may have heard of the society of
the offices of the revolutionary war
created the society
to continue fellowship and to help
support families of wounded
or or killed officers and they call
themselves the society of cincinnati
they thought of themselves as like
cincinnati so
the the myth the story is he's working
he's plowing the field but he has a
reputation of public service
and they come and they say we need you
and they put him in they make him
dictator
he solves the crisis and he goes back to
his field that's sort of the classic
roman understanding of of working for
the public good
for the things that are good for the
public so
anyway obviously the americans reject
this way of dealing with
the need occasionally for vast executive
power to be concentrated on one hand
but hamilton goes on to say that if you
have a feeble executive you'll get
feeble execution of government and
you'll get a bad government
you must have an energetic presidency
and that means it must be unified
so it can't be a plural like a three
like a committee of three or committee
of
six pennsylvania essentially had a
committee of 12
as its executive with with one of them
chosen to be called president
um so it couldn't be a committee
executive and it couldn't be an
executive that was checked by a council
that had independent authority so most
states
not quite all but most states had a
council that
had to approve the actions of the
governors at least many of the actions
of the governors
that unity is conducive to energy will
not be disputed decision
activity secrecy and dispatch those are
common qualities that are mentioned
during this
period will generally characterize the
proceedings of one man
in a much more eminent degree than the
proceedings of any greater number
and in proportion as the number is
increased these qualities will be
diminished
so there's structural grounds why the
president
may be in a position to take the
initiative to act aggressively
remember at the beginning of the country
congress was more often not in session
than in session
was in session typically six months one
year three months the next
so that's nine months out of 24. so on
average if you just pick the date at
random
congress is not in session so things can
happen and in those days it took a while
of course to gather congress because at
the very beginning there was no
telegraph
and there were no railroads later some
decades later you'll have both
telegraphs and railroads so congress can
assemble
more quickly now let's let's
uh move ahead a few years to 1793.
so war has broken out in europe between
france
and its neighbors word of the conflict
makes its way across the atlantic
early in the year and the washington
administration has to decide what to do
the complication was that france and the
united states had a treaty from 1778
the treaty that brought france to the
aid of the american revolutionaries and
maybe their aid was decisive to the
winning the revolutionary war
but that treaty also had a provision
that said if france in the future were
at war
then the united states was obligated to
protect
french interests and colonies in the
caribbean
so
there isn't time to tell the whole story
about this but the key is that
washington and his cabinet
you know having having to decide what do
we do this was our great ally
this is a nation that probably made it
possible for the independent we seem to
have this treaty obligation
but would it be wise for us do we have
we don't really have a navy how could we
really
carry out this obligation so washington
and his cabinet agreed
and washington announced publicly that
the us would remain neutral
in the european war on april 27th he
issued
what we call his proclamation of
neutrality that wasn't the official
title of it but that's what
we historians and others have off as you
usually called it
and so that proclamation of neutrality
informed
the nations in europe there were at war
that the u.s was a neutral and so
neutrals under international law
had certain rights that had to be
respected so if you're shipping
goods from one neutral country to
another neutral country across the
atlantic ocean
the belligerents are not allowed just to
capture those goods
food stuffs or whatever or manufactured
goods because it would be useful for
their war effort
but also american citizens so so the
belligerents had to know
that the u.s was neutral but also
american citizens had to know
because there was a lot of feeling for
the french and a lot of americans wanted
to help the french
in its war and if those americans who
owned ships loaded those ships with
goods
food and arms and things like that they
might be violating international law
they might be captured by the enemy
and washington is saying to them you
can't expect i'm going to come to your
aid
because you because we're a neutral
nation and you must respect the laws of
neutrality
u.s citizens as private citizens so this
proclamation was hugely controversial
pro-french feeling ran high in the
country not surprisingly
congress was not in session and not
scheduled to return until december of
1793
many americans opposed the policy of
neutrality and some questioned
whether the president even had the
authority to make such a decision
writing under the pseudonym pacificus
alexander hamilton who was then the
secretary of the treasury
wrote seven essays defending
washington's decision
as both constitutional and prudent or
wise
and also as not violating the
stipulations
of the treaty he's a long discussion of
how to understand the treaty
i won't go into that his first essay is
on the constitutional issue
that's all i'm going to quote from here
in a minute
now thomas jefferson reads
these seven essays by me by hamilton
defending washington's actions
jefferson was as you probably know the
secretary of state he supported
neutrality the policy in the cabinet
meetings we actually have his notes from
those meetings from the cabinet meetings
he was the secretary
he kept the notes but when he read
hamilton's broad interpretation of
presidential power he wrote to his
friend and protege
james madison who was not in the
administration but was a leader in the
house representatives
and and this is part of what he wrote
for god's sakes my dear sir
take up your pen select the most
striking heresies
and cut him two pieces in the face of
the public
so jefferson was somewhat exercised you
could say about
this defense that had been given by by
hamilton
madison writing as helvidius obliged
with five essays
all of them focused on the
constitutional question
madison didn't challenge the wisdom of
the policy
uh he didn't challenge the way in the
term the treaties were interpreted
all he challenged was hamilton's first
essay
defending the constitutionality of this
proclamation
so that's what i want to turn to then is
excerpts
from hamilton writing as pacifica so
that hamilton
uses pseudonym pacificus so
i'm just going to read a little bit of
this and again since you can't see it
but just follow along as best you can
and then we'll see how
uh adamantly madison disagreed and then
i'm going to show one more thing and
kind of bring this
to a conclusion so hamilton writes
uh first in what isn't on the slide for
those who can see it
first he writes that a proclamation
isn't really a legislative power it's
not really a judicial power so it must
be executive because what what else is
less
left but executive but then he gives
more information he talks about how
pr how the executive is in charge of of
the is the organ of intercourse with
other nations his interpreter of
national treaties
so it fits in with other expressed
presidential powers that's his first
argument
but then most importantly he quotes the
beginning words of article two the
vesting clause
the executive power shall be vested in a
president united states of america
and he says that all that that so
all possible executive power has been
brought has been given to the president
unless the constitution takes some away
unless it makes an exception now and it
made three exceptions
it gave the senate a role in the
president making high-level executive
appointments
and ambassadorial appointments were
obviously involved in foreign policy the
senate must approve
who the secretary of state is going to
be not people lower down in the totem
pole but people at the top the senate
even though they're executive officers
to serve the president the senate must
approve so the senate has a little bit
of executive power
the senate has to approve treaties
hamilton's point is that otherwise the
president would have the full power over
treaties but the constitution says
otherwise
and also he says of course the
legislature has the power to declare
war and grant letters of mock and
reprisal but hamilton's constitutional
position is
when a and this was a norm at the time
madison
denied it but but uh denied its
application here
is that when a general power is granted
and there are exceptions that are cut
out
the exceptions are to be interpreted
strictly
narrowly as a general norm of
interpreting
a document like a constitution so here's
hamilton's conclusion while therefore
the legislature can alone declare war
can alone actually transfer the nation
from a state of peace to a state of war
all right only the legislature according
to hamilton very pro-presidency but
according to him only the legislature
can transfer the nation from a state of
peace to a state of war it belongs to
the executive power
to do whatever else the law of nations
cooperating with the treaties of the
country and join
in the intercourse of the united states
with foreign powers
in other words the whole power of
foreign policy
comes in through the vesting clause but
some of it has been
carved out and given to the senate two
things and then to the full congress
this one other big thing the power to
declare war
and grant led us american reprisal now
i'm not going to go into it but if any
of you have
studied locke's second treatise of
government so locke was writing
this famous british philosopher and
political philosophy john locke
he was writing a hundred years before
these events and then his second
treatise in chapter 13
he says there are two kinds of executive
in principle there's a domestic
executive carries out domestic law
and there's what you might call the
international executive
who exercises international uh conducts
international relations
makes foreign policy locke says
you can call this the federative power
this foreign policy power he then says
i don't really care what name you use
but it's commonly called the federator
power
and then locke said in any
well-regulated state
those two executives are brought
together you don't want to have one
person
with the power of the state to regulate
to carry out domestic policy
and a whole separate person with the
power of the state to carry out
foreign policy so in all regulated all
well regulated commonwealths
you bring those together into one person
so hamilton doesn't mention
locke but he's clearly but he knew lock
and they all the leading founders new
lock it was
essentially required reading at colleges
and universities throughout the country
um and madison in particular i'm not
going to read everything from madison
but he specifically took
issue with locke knowing that locke was
kind of the inspiration for this
hamiltonian
position so madison now responds after
these seven essays have come out with
five essays of his own and let me read a
little bit
let me put up okay the uh
so madison's writing us helvidius let me
read a little bit of this
the basis of pacificus's reasoning is we
perceive
the extraordinary doctrine that the
powers of making war
and treaties are in their nature
executive and therefore
comprehended in the general grant of
executive power were not specifically
and strictly accepted out of that grant
the natural province of the executive
magistrate is to execute laws
as that of the legislature is to make
laws all his acts therefore executive
must presuppose
the existence of laws to be executed
so this notion that treaty making and
war making by their nature our executive
is according to him to madison
completely wrong
um he then in a famous passage is
often quoted for those who can seize
near the bottom of this slide
war is in fact the true nurse of
executive aggrandizement
in war physical force is to be to be
created it is the executive which is to
direct it
in war the public treasures ought to be
unlocked and it is the executive hand
which is to dispense them
and then it goes on and it mentions that
if glory is to be had in war it's the
executives going to get the glory
the strongest passions the most
dangerous weaknesses of the human breast
ambition avarice vanity on the honorable
or venial love of fame there's a good
kind of love of fame
but there's also a more being the love
of fame all are in conspiracy
against the desire and duty of peace
hence it has grown into an axiom that
the executive is the department of power
most distinguished by its propensity to
war
it's more the executive than the
judiciary of the congress that wants to
go to war
i mean there have been exceptions in
american history but that's the general
argument
hence it is the practice of all states
in proportion
as they are free to disarm this
propensity of its influence
so the key thing in free states is to
disarm the propensity of the executive
to go to war so this is quite a contrast
between these two
um two men one from virginia one from
new york who were
close allies at the constitutional
convention who
authored together all but five of the
federalist papers as you may know
hamilton wrote the most then madison the
next and
john jay who was ill only wrote five
who each led the pro-constitution
forces in their respective states in the
constitutional
uh ratifying conventions and
successfully because virginia and new
york
both ratified in the summer 1788 yet
here they are a few years later
engaged in a pretty big disagreement
now uh you will often see
in the scholarship that i cover and that
i'm you know i'm involved in
you will often see madison's position
quoted
over and over again by contemporary
scholars
however hamilton's position not so much
he's almost sort of the forgotten child
of this debate
among these academics that right on this
topic
yet the united states congress when it
did convene
in december of 1793 it did not
challenge the president on either the
policy
of neutrality or on the constitutional
basis
on which it was made there was no
constitutional investigation or
challenge
did you mr president have even the
authority to do this
even if it was a good thing to do
policy-wise and there was none of that
when the congress came back
one final founding ever document that i
want to take a quick look at
uh is to have it up here it's bass feet
kinky so
i mentioned we'll just look at a couple
sentences so this is the first
war powers case the supreme court ever
addressed so this is in 1800 so we're
11 years under the new constitution
it began operating in uh in 1789
and we're 11 years later was written in
87 ratified in 88 went into effect in
89.
so 11 years later a legal issue arose
from the so-called quasi-war with france
of the late 1790s sometimes called the
undeclared war with france
it was a limited naval war in the north
atlantic
it wasn't a land war and it didn't
spread beyond the north atlantic
lasted for several years it was not
declared
a war by congress but it was authorized
in different
statutes especially the crete that
authorized the creation of new naval
ships
uh the fighting itself was authorized by
congress
with certain strictures put on what was
allowed
so the question before the court was
whether a
war of this sort which is not declared
as a war
is it for a court case legally a war
in particular when it came to applying
the laws of salvage
for ships captured on the high seas the
factual
the facts are very complicated so i
don't have to get into those
uh take a lot of time but what rules
of salvage do you apply because there's
different rules that apply in peace time
and in wartime and was this legally a
war
even though it wasn't declared right
there was no declaration of war
it was authorized but not declared so
bushrod washington in those days 1800
this is three years before john marshall
joins the court
and so before marshall joins the court
the justices typically wrote their own
opinions
uh and then if enough agreed on one side
that was the opinion of the court once
marshall comes on
he promotes uh
often unanimous opinions by the court or
relatively few so you have a real
formal statement of the court's opinion
as a whole
so this is bushrod washington what he
does in this
excerpt from the case is he
distinguishes two kinds of war
both legitimate both legal
first is a war declared in form
so if congress declares war then you
have
war of the perfect kind he calls that a
perfect war
but congress can also authorize a much
more limited engagement
and that's imperfect war but it's still
legally a war
okay that's imperfect war so
um so where does all this get us so i
have this slide
which i was kind of proud of in putting
it together
let me just just show you visually what
it looks like and i'll tell you what it
says
and then i'll just make a few final uh
comments
so the point of the slide is this if if
you look at all these materials and
obviously there's more one could look at
but i think i've given you a good
overview of the key material
i think the constitution gives us
significant guidance
as to who gets to exercise who gets to
go to war
who gets to authorize the use of the
military by the
by the united states at one extreme is
presidential power and that's the power
to repel sudden attacks
everybody at the founding agreed on that
at the other extreme
is congress's power or obligation to
move the nation from a state of peace to
a state of war
but you can come in from those extremes
and you can see
uh situations uh conditions where the
where one side or the other might also
be able to act but not at the extreme
so congress we know from bass b kingy
can
authorize a limited war presumably it
can authorize reprisals
right because it can grant ish letters
of mock and reprisal
the president i would argue but i won't
explain the details of the argument
the president i would say also has the
constitutional authority to engage in a
preemptive strike
think of the 1967 if you know anything
about the 1967
mideast war between israel and its
neighbors israel was convinced and
apparent apparently rightly so that its
neighbors were going to attack it first
so it didn't wait to take the blow
it attacked its neighbors first
airfields and such
that would have been used to attack
israel that's a pure pm
preemptive strike and i think you could
argue the president has that power as
well
protecting american citizens and commas
was one that at the time of the founding
that seemed to be recognition
that under the various constitutional
provisions the president had some
authority there
and then in the middle here are more
questionable
issues where case by case you might have
to decide
make a judgment as to who has the
authority treaty violations foreign
policy
more generally the promotion of vital
american interests
and humanitarian interventions that
might require the use of force
so with that let me just let me just
conclude with a couple of
paragraphs that will bring this together
i'll put up my blank
conclusion slide and i'll read you my
conclusion so what do we conclude
there is no avoiding the complications
the separation of powers presents for
american foreign policy
and in particular for the exercise of
the war power
yet the constitution is more than just
an invitation to the two political
branches
to struggle for control over the war
power
rather the constitution structures and
empowers the congress
to be a representative and deliberative
institution with final authority over
whether to move the nation from a state
of peace
to a state of war and the same
constitution created a single energetic
executive and empowered it to act
decisively and often secretly
to protect american lives and interest
in a dangerous world
in the decades after world war ii we had
gotten away from the notion
before time of most of you of course
we've gotten away from the notion
that congress had to formally auth the
congress
uh had to formally authorize any
military actions
that the president wished to undertake
that as many people argue that congress
never had to authorize
anything the president could always just
go first so even a major engagement like
the korean war
in the early 50s which was funded by
congress and the draft was extended by
congress so congress supported what
truman was trying to do in the war
it was never actually authorized by
congress
thus when things weren't going well in
korea after a couple of years and the
war became
unpopular people started calling it mr
truman's war
mr truman's war because the congress
hadn't
in an official way authorized it and
bought into it
even though the later vietnam war was
authorized by congress in the gulf of
tonka resolution 1964
that war engended a belief among many
that over the years
congress had ceded to the president its
proper constitutional responsibility
to decide whether to go to war when war
did not
already exist consequently
the last three major military and
military engagements undertaken by the
united states
this is interesting and quite in
contrast to korea have all been
formally authorized by congress so what
am i talking without a formal
declaration of war what am i talking
about
the first gulf war of 1991 you have
formal
they're called aumfs authorization for
use of military force
they evolved they the often resolutions
but they have full force of law
so the first gulf war was authorized by
an aumf
the war against al qaeda and the taliban
regime
after the attacks of 9 11 was authorized
by an aumf
and the more recent war against saddam
hussein's regime in iraq
that started in 2003 was authorized by
an aumf
now where the war powers act or war
power's resolution in 1973
fits into all this obviously there's no
time to discuss now
maybe in the q a we can talk about it
so very final thought on the war powers
controversy
scholars policy makers and others tend
to be either pro-constitution
or pro-presidency but what we ought to
be
is not the advocate of one institution
or the other
but rather advocates of the constitution
we ought to be pro-constitution
not pro-presidency or pro-congress on
these matters
and in some cases indeed in many cases
the constitution will
side with the with presidential
initiative
without prior approval by congress but
in
others the constitution says to the
president
you should not act unless and until
congress approves in my view
the wisdom embedded in the
constitution's provisions
never ceases to surprise thank you very
[Applause]
much